[Music]
hey come on get your stuff let's
go let's try that
again
a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who
were running out of it until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want for
me New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you why who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
is he Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all day
what do you want for me you have no idea
what those girls have come why don't
you I think he can see into the future
are he's trying to change what
happens Julia get
downar your future was almost so
different do if you want to live you
have to trust
me
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
[Music]
little